[Musique]
bonjour joseph losey
bonjour moi j'ai eu le temps vous êtes
le maire du françois officiellement
depuis dimanche un homme fidèle qui
s'inscrit dans la continuité de ce que
fait déjà le mouvement populaire
franciscain la tête de la mairie avec
notamment votre prédécesseur maurice
antiste joseph losey en cours du journal
de claude gracia a parlé de l'école du
maine mais n'y a pas que celle ci est
également celle danemark l apr est
couché situation pénible la sécurité des
élèves n'est pas assurée avez vous un
problème avec les écoles du françois
elle n'en est pas là pas de cocher had
marque et près du pont séraphin vous
avez résolu de penser à prendre touché
puisque si le lieu où on va construire
la nouvelle école donc les études sont
bien avancées et la construction
commencera bientôt
est ce que ça te connais pas plus
générale avec les établissements
scolaires en termes de sécurité
d'accueil des élèves
et puis des piles appris à capuche inez
autres ni un souci ou savent que c'est
des coleman nicklas assez ancien donc
c'est l'école matinée classes des écoles
le construit dans les années 50-60 pour
timo matinée à l'école et un autre mot
maître profiter de mots c'est l'école de
la whey l'école du manot mari pendant
les études allaient ils tiennent des
déficits nous constaté des fissures dans
les radios nous commencer des travaux
et puis entreprises là il fait ce
travail là pendant des vacances de la
toussaint et de l'api tomber l'autre et
nous obliger cette voie là par l'école
pendant six mois pour nous ça finit
travail là nous paie pas keating koala
aller et puis de lui 90 morts
toujours sur la question des
infrastructures joseph losey ample
françois qui est présenté je proposais
le direct beaucoup de fierté comme étant
une grande ville sportive mais toujours
la question des infrastructures
il se trouve que samedi dernier j'étais
hall pour garder vos merveilleux
basketteurs du wax mais quand même
vous n'êtes pas un peu gêné de les voir
évoluer dans une telle salle
je suis presque odieux c'est gênant
c'est même manque de respect pour eux
je suis gêné l'équipe municipale est
gêné tout le monde sait en martinique
que nous avons obtenu des subventions et
que le financement était quasiment
bouclé puisque le ministre lors du
dernier gouvernement est venu dans ce
rôle de sport j'y étais et ne voit-il
pas que ça de financement bouclé nous
apprenons que le dernier gouvernement a
coupé un prescription de dix ans de
l'état qui ne met pas l'argent qu'il
faut presque par dix le plan de
financement mais nous y arrivons parce
que nous avons un nouveau plan de
financement que nous avons à arrêter et
chose pour mise par nos ce sera fait il
ya aussi le stade de france 3 pour le
club franciscain paix mais vous savez
monsieur viol tant que la plaine
sportive du françois
c'est la plus étendue de martinique et
même des antilles vous savez quel effort
nous avons fait en matière de structures
pour les jeunes sportifs pendant les
vacances de toussaint
vous avez dû entendre à la radio partout
combien de stage il y a eu partout pour
les jeunes je suis un compétiteur je
sais que l'équipe première
mérite mieux et maurice antiste le
meilleur temps c'était sa priorité et ça
demeure ma priorité de faire l'éclairage
c'est la question des finances qui vous
gène monsieur le maire pour une ville de
20 mille habitants est prêt pour un
budget de près de 40 millions d'euros
gérer c'est anticiper vous vous ne savez
pas gérer c'est anticiper et toutes les
familles martiniquaises vous diront
qu'un gérer c'est anticiper c'est aussi
vrai pour les collectivités par les
temps qui courent je suis pas celui qui
pleure mais par les temps qui courent
nous savons bien que le gouvernement de
manière drastique a su abc énormément la
dgf
nous ne pouvons pas éternellement
augmenter d épauler les gens vous disent
il faut faire nous faut faire mais sans
augmenter les impôts
donc nous nous voulons avoir une gestion
très très strictes pour que les gens du
françois ne tombe pas dans des impôts
donc nous le ferons chose promise chose
due c'était la priorité de mon ressenti
et sa demeure
ma priorité et c'est pour cela que
l'équipe municipale et c'est pour cela
que par exemple l'amérique et de fleurs
ont quand même du patrimoine de la ville
franciscaine tombe en ruine
lentement mais sûrement et je suis à la
mairie j étais hier soit jusqu'à 21h30
ouais l'ancienne mairie qui est qui
n'étant pas classé monument historique
mais l'ancienne mairie si vous preniez
d'histoire de martinique vous voulez que
l'ancien musique est faite de pierres de
taille et et de bois ça va demeurer non
pas un endroit où il ya des bureaux mais
nous allons en faire un florent
patrimoniale oui les services de votre
municipalité sont éclatés est-ce que ça
nuit
est-ce que ça nuit à l'efficacité de vos
services on pourrait croire qu'un
service ou en groupe et ça peut faire en
sorte que les gens se secoue 3 sur coup
trois mais on aurait par exemple avoir
une seule photocopieuse au moins avec un
fonctionner je veux gagner photocopieuse
10 10 - compagnie papiers pour sa
librairie photocopieuse à yushu est
offert au togo vit bas moubarak
est ce que le h mirador dynaco dr mais
c'est vrai que avec moi aussi comme avec
monde santis nous voulons avoir une
gestion rigoureuse
il faut vous avez vous référer à maurice
antiste comme ça tout le temps
non je n'ai pas vous affranchir de lui
monsieur je suis maire du françois rey
est donc toute la plénitude de mes
fonctions
oui mais on ne peut pas me le dire comme
ou santis qui a passé 24 ans doit me
dufranc soir quand le balance j'ai
besoin je suis j'ai simplement si vous
continuez je vous le dis je vous le dis
j'aurai besoin de son concours de son
conseil parce qu'il demeure conseiller
municipal comme les autres jouer mais je
ne sais qu'on sait alors votre ville la
plus grande de l'espace sud 1 oui ce
qu'on ne laisse pas su dès que l'on peut
considérer comme la capitale de la zone
puisque mon nouveau clermont du cosmos
cet esprit qui pas envie descendent en
ville de calais françois parce que
apparemment ni tout d'ageila c'est une
ville attractive qui peut garder son
attractivité même si l'insee dit que
vous perdez des habitants oui comme
presque toutes les villes de martinique
nous perd des habitants et nous savons
ce que c'est que d'avoir des enfants
dans une famille qui partait qu'il est
seul les les parents mes enfants ne sont
pas en martinique
ils sont ailleurs et cela dans toutes
les familles martiniquaises c'est vrai
que nous offrant soit comme ailleurs
nous voulons être actif comment faire
non seulement la mairie il doit mettre
sa part mais aussi les privés et autres
cette semaine je vous invite demain
monti demain soir il y avait remis sage
aux amusements clément mais c'est moi
qui l habitation c'est bon c'est pour le
reste c'est là qu'on soit le plus grand
nombre de martiniquais et pour le reste
et attractivité vous avez dit que les
gens du sud via nos francs soit parce
que nous avons des structures presque
toutes les deux indications ont quelque
chose au françois
et quand les gens viennent du françois
viennent au françois le dimanche en
dehors de toute tradition ils viennent à
l'église du françois
oui parce qu'il ya des chorales il y
avait qu à la risée des écoles de haute
taille c'est une des communes ya le plus
qu elle joseph nos âmes vous serez maire
jusqu'en 2020 puisque c'est cette
mission que que vous êtes
adjugé mais les trois prochaines années
est ce que ça ne risque pas de créer de
vives tensions au sein du mouvement
populaire franciscaine parce qu'il
faudra bien désigner celui qui serait
qui arrivera après vous puisque vous
n'avez vous l'avais déjà dit vous serez
là jusqu'en 2020 seulement oui monsieur
jiva jusqu'en 2020 et tout le monde le
sait mais il n'y aura pas de problème
cela se fera sans eux parce que
l'ouvrant aux pierres franciscain c'est
un vieux mouvement
c'est un vieux bar à ben voilà c'est un
vieux mouvement avec excusez
l'expression avec des personnes d'un
certain âge qui n'ont peut être pas pu
préparer la transition quand je vous dis
un mouvement jouets dû dire pouvoir très
âgées ouais
cela vous plairait mieux mais parce que
ça fait énormément d'année kylie a dit
j'ai tissé jeanne mas et ses tiges et
malaga zotti mais actuellement l'équipe
municipale est là mais n'ayez crainte le
moment francis le moment pour les
franciscains c'est un mouvement qui vit
et voulaient vider
j'en suis sûr on reverra cld à la nage
et le secrétaire général du mouvement
qui est actuellement en congé
oui il est en congé comme deux bouddhas
comme il en compte aujourd'hui il boude
il n'y a pas deux bouts de vie au
mouvement populaire franciscains si vous
étiez si vous étiez avec nous dimanche
vous auriez vu que la salle était pleine
le club là j étais là un ordre de marche
avec tout le reste
dernière question rapidement la
concurrence sera entre claude alain
lagier marie-france tino pour la tête de
liste aux lancers rien la vérité
d'aujourd'hui n'est peut-être pas la
vérité de demain
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nos
joseph nous on rappelle que vous êtes le
maire du françois depuis dimanche
dernier bonne journée c'est beaucoup
dire merci
[Musique]